revolvers as we know them have been
around for over 170 years and yet in an
age of sci-fi beam-weapons
high-powered sniper rifles and unmanned
drones this relic from a bygone age is
still a common sight in games and movies
today but how did the weapon that won
the west end up in our fiction and why
is injured before we talk about Dirty
Harry Deckard and revolver ocelot
dishing out their own brand of frontier
justice we need to take a look at the
century that separates the conception of
the weapon and the modern characters
that become synonymous with it
weapon Smiths were experimented with
revolving mechanisms as far back as the
late 16th century with Chinese gunsmith
tat Xiao Shi Shen created national a
Zhang a set of muskets that revolved
around a central spear and put it to
work defending castle walls but the Wild
West granddaddy as we know it didn't
show up until the 1830s when one Samuel
Colt painted the revolving mechanism in
Britain in 1835 and in the u.s. a year
later but this new type of weapon would
not reach widespread use until around
1846 during the American Mexican War the
first iteration of the revolver were
muzzle loaders meaning that every round
had to be individually placed into each
chamber with a necessary gunpowder ball
and caps before they could be fired as
you can imagine it took up a lot of time
to load fire and reload and as such
wasn't exactly popular some soldiers
would carry multiple revolvers on their
horse or hip to ensure that they could
stay in the fight knowing Colt patterns
in the revolver would expire in 1856 the
competing Smith & Wesson company began
prototyping a revolver cartridge with
the aim of solving the woes of long
reloading times this innovation would
create a huge surge in use especially
within the military with a vast number
of them being sold to both sides of the
American Civil War in 1861 and four
years after too many a settler cattle
rustlin cowboy looking to find a home
and establish their fortune the western
states for America the revolver would be
their first weapon of choice
so began the era of the gunslinger as we
know it the Wild West era is typically
considered to be from the civil wars and
in 1865 up until 1895
it's these 30 years of history that are
perhaps most synonymous with the iconic
firearm and as a result the era is one
of the most important and explored time
periods in modern entertainment the
lawlessness and wild nature of America's
growing lands made these weapons almost
a necessity to some degree or another
and the technology behind them continued
to develop even as settlers were finding
their feet the most common type of
revolver was a single action meaning
that putting the trigger would result in
the hammer of the weapon falling to fire
the bullet once however the hammer
itself had to be manually cocked and
chambers rotated conversely double
action means that the pull of a trigger
does two things wrench the hammer back
while the lining of the next chamber and
send the hammer crashing forward to fire
the next round the best virtual
representation of this change in firing
style in an evolution of the revolver
can be seen in rockstars Red Dead
Redemption titles in these games through
the passage of time John Marston and
Arthur Morgan's Arsenal improves
reflecting the timeline along which the
revolver change in real life both
characters start with a revolvers that
are slow and deliberate but as in-game
time passes guns with improved shoot
ability appear they move from single
action to double action and eventually
on to automatic pistols as in the real
world the self-loading pistol the
automatic pistol becomes really the more
practical weapon over time by the end of
the Second World War things like the
colt 1911 have just taken over funnily
enough from the colt 45
predecessor the Single Action Army and
by that time they really are affixed
almost as the weapon of the Old West
along with the Winchester rifle and
various others the revolver starts to
become Alma not exclusively but more
exclusively the weapon of gunfighters of
cowboys Hollywood has a key part to play
in that from the early 20th century
through to the late 1960s westerns were
the most popular movie genre around one
of the earliest movies ever created was
the Great Train Robbery and the 1903
silent film featured revolvers
prominently most famously with just as
Dee Barnes
taking aim and firing directly towards
the theater audience in this regard the
use of a revolver is inherently tied to
the birth of filmmaking according to
film industry legend the first
feature-length movie created out of
Hollywood as we know it was in 1914
Western the [ __ ] Man which also
featured revolvers it's safe to say
revolvers were very much in the DNA of
entertainment from the very beginning
and as other mediums appeared around it
that heritage has endured the idea of
the Wild West was so instrumental to
American culture that it became a focal
point for their entertainment with a
Wild West so fresh in the memory come
the birth of cinema every writer
director and actor were already
intimately familiar with the
larger-than-life myths and legends of
the West the Wild West was rich with
potential for heroes and villains so the
genre was an easy win for those
interested in telling exciting stories
to new audiences even today the image of
a gunslinger is very culturally powerful
one whether it's a down-on-his-luck
cowboy on the run from the Pinkertons or
a cigar sucking man with no name it
three coffins really and naturally with
every gunslinger cattle rancher sheriff
or bandit the grace the cinema screen
the revolver was never too far sight
since its conception and production the
revolver has become a key part of many a
myth and legend of the Old West
cementing it into the culture of
American cinema one famous myth that
made it into films and games is that of
Fanning the hammer where a gunslinger is
holding down the trigger and pulling
back the hammer with that off hand in
order to rapid fire all six rounds in
reality though this isn't accurate the
process of priming and firing as such
speed does not lend itself to effective
combat in most situations as it's
inaccurate and would mean stepping out
from any cover the shooter may have and
it would also potentially damage the
weapon too instead this flamboyant
process was a popular attraction in
shooting shows where marksmen
entertained crowds with pistol based
performances and feats of accuracy the
regardless it seems to be a skill many
cinematic gunslingers have inherited and
can utilize to great effect the
association and reputation that this
weapon hand with the hero archetypes of
blockbuster movies was something that
was maintained to the Golden Age of
cinema and well into the 60s and 70s
thanks to actors like John Wayne and
Clint Eastwood it wasn't just on screen
whether a revolver was the weapon of
choice for the actors revolvers were
much easier to fire with blank rounds
while automatic weapons required
adapting to use the film safe ammunition
so with something so reliable so badass
and so iconic
there wasn't much reason to change
weapons it's no surprise then that this
famous firearm would retain that
reputation into video games with arcade
cabinets like outlaw and gun fights
games imitating old West's duels between
a player and a virtual opponents started
to appear in the 1970s and the revolver
then went on to make its way into genres
far beyond that of virtual westerns both
a real-life characteristics as well as
the assumed tropes that surround the
revolver a huge reasons as to why is
appeared in such a vast list of wildly
different video games for instance it's
a great weapon for a horror title
whether usual six-round capacity means
that you have to be accurate and
deliberate with your shots creating a
sense of tension in the combat revolvers
also usually have a slower rate
fire than other pistols in the game
creating a sense of panic as enemies
close in it appeared in the grandfather
of the survival horror genre 1992 SR
glowing in the dark Barret played to
this exact trope
similarly 2014's the evil would then
present the revolver as the first weapon
you find in the game and struggling to
find ammo for it was a core part of the
early game experience further playing on
that feeling of needing to make every
shot count I think with films especially
and actually when you're gaming as well
there's something to the limited
ammunition aspect of a revolver people
intuitively know that it's usually a six
shot you know that the hero or the
villain has got six shots to do what
they want to do you can show them
pausing to reload you can use the reload
and animation to slow down how rapidly
they can shoot and then probably up the
damage as well and we see that in the
movies so something about almost the
huge leap forward in technology in the
19th century six shots instead of one is
amazing time moves on it's almost the
other way around it's like the number of
shots is a badge of honor though you
know you you know how to use this thing
because you've only got six shots but if
you hit them with it they're going down
it's a common sight in the
post-apocalyptic genre as well due to
the trope around the revolver that it is
more reliable more robust and easy to
maintain
obviously these are traits that
extremely useful if you want your
firearm to work under world-ending
conditions be that the nuclear winters
of the russian wastelands the
radioactive dust of the mojave desert or
the fungus infected ruins of boston the
revolver is a mainstay in many works of
science fiction as well its iconic shape
and silhouette helped create weapons
that players and viewers feel like
they're familiar with even if they are
transformed into something futuristic or
otherworldly rick Deckard's gun from
Blade Runner for example makes great use
of this as the weapon is constructed
from a 44 caliber revolver with much of
its parts replaced with a bolt-action
rifle it feels completely bespoke and
tied to the blade or in a universe when
you see it but still fundamentally a
revolver in look and feel if not in the
way it behaves from an engineering
standpoint games like Borderlands
destiny and even Final Fantasy 8 take a
similar approach putting bizarre and
interesting twists on the base revolver
the beauty of doing this is that it
allows players to make assumptions about
the weapon there
ting but it's slow but boy will it be
powerful its existence in video games
also allows developers to be flexible
with the way a revolver performs for the
sake of valuable variety in gameplay
games often let players choose a power
and accuracy option over ammo capacity
and rates of fire a skill cannon in the
hands of a team fortress 2 spy or the
last digit high damage sidearm in Call
of Duty and Battlefield aren't exactly
accurate to classic revolvers but very
much carry the spirit of one its spirit
also seeps into the characters that
wield it when you see an antagonist
clutching one of these hand cannons it
says something about them it denotes a
sense of skill that they're a
professional that they're experienced
and have a touch of the old-school about
them cache remind backs the very first
time you saw a revolver ocelot just as
title tells you so much about the
character which is reinforced further
when you see his skill and the weird
deeply personal borderline erotic
connection he has with his gun in Metal
Gear Solid now I'll show you why they
called me
or afar such is the renowned of the
weapon that acts as an interesting story
device in male Gear Solid it serves as a
way to show that Auto loss is the
antithesis of Solid Snake snakes so calm
is a weapon that's used for stealth and
infiltration both objectives that define
snake Ocelot Colt single-action revolver
on the other hand is a large loud
showboating peacekeeper that literally
cannot be silenced such as Ocelot this
kind of mythological history of the
revolver is just fixed now it's with us
and so we almost have parallel worlds we
have the pop culture the entertainment
world where the revolver is more favored
and more used and in the real world
really falling out of favor so they have
this long tail for a long time before we
see the revolver disappear even though
it's strictly obsolete as a military or
or a police weapon where it does cut it
is in the big screen on TV on your
screen playing games because you can
follow the trope of increased damage
increased accuracy is in theory and this
is something that popular media likes to
do a lot they take a theoretical
advantage like in theory it might be
slightly more accurate than a moving
barrel on a self-loading pistol and they
turn it up to 11 and it's the most
accurate and powerful weapon in the
whole game or the whole movie depending
on who's wielding it so it's this kind
of unreality that we see this with
various things but the revolver is one
of them so the revolver still a viable
weapon if you're in a movie it's not
really any more in real life such as the
revolvers long lasting impression and
iconic form I bet if I asked you what
kind of weapon did India Jones take the
sword spin it down with what weapon does
Shepard use to betray Rocha modern
warfare 2 or what firearm does Dirty
Harry wield I know what you thinking
there would be a bloody good chance
you'd be able to tell me from the weapon
that won the West to a cinematic action
hero staple the virtual hand cannons we
see in so many of our video games the
legacy of the revolver spans nearly two
hundred years in myth and legend on the
silver screen and in the virtual
representations we see in our games and
it shows no sign of going away anytime
soon
thank you so much for joining us on this
first episode of loadout we've got loads
more plan for you much more than just
the silver screen six years so make sure
you subscribe and catch us next week for
a brand new episode